What if Mars
astronauts get infected
by some kind of crazy
Martian disease?
Do we just leave them out there?
Hey spacefarers.
Trace here with our weekly
D News space update.
I know it sounds like a
science fiction horror film,
but seriously,
pathogens may exist
on Mars that could potentially
infect visiting humans.
It's possible.
Back in the 1960s,
NASA was worried
that astronauts from Apollo 11
may have unknowingly picked up
some kind of alien bacteria
while traipsing around
on the moon.
And in response, they rescued
them from their splashdown,
put them in special
isolation suits,
and into a quarantine
trailer for weeks
until they were completely
cleared and safe.
NASA has long been concerned
about bacterial contamination
of their spaced-out
humans, checking them
before their flights and
then rechecking them after.
Not only do we want
to avoid some kind
of alien super plague--
that would be really bad--
but contamination of alien
worlds with Earth bacteria
could really screw
things up out there.
To protect us from messing
up each other's planets
is NASA's Planetary
Protection Office.
But still, sometimes
bad things happen.
Astronauts going to Mars will
spend months and maybe even
years exposed to
only each other.
Because of this
limited environment,
the bacteria living in
their digestive tract,
nasal passages, and upper
airways will mutate,
and their body's immune
system will slowly weaken.
One infection of concern
is staphylococcus.
It's commonly found during
sweeps of the International
Space Station already.
This little guy can become
MRSA, an unfortunately common
infection fought in hospitals,
prisons, and nursing homes,
places where immune
systems are weaker.
Once humans show up
in the red planet,
they would instantly contaminate
any of their equipment
with bacteria.
We just can't help it.
They're everywhere.
The mere presence
of humans would
cause a bacterial infestation,
and Mars's environment
would be akin to a trial by
fire for an invasive species.
Bacteria on a contaminated
Rover, for example,
could infect areas of Mars
suitable for Earth life.
Then, without competition
from other strains,
that area would become a Petri
dish for mutated superbugs.
So what's the plan to
protect NASA's astronauts
from getting up there
and becoming infected?
Beforehand, we could irradiate
their foods to kill bacteria.
They do that already.
But the effect of
long-term ingestion
of microorganism-free
food on our gut bacteria
isn't really clear.
While on Mars, NASA has set
up already human restriction
zones, where a robot will have
to check the area before one
of us meatbags can visit.
But even with restrictions,
inevitably, someone's
going to get sick.
In the case of
illness, according
to the planetary
protection office,
one crew member will
have the responsibility
to implement planetary
protection protocol
and will determine how to act.
NASA will monitor the health
of their men and women,
and hopefully the
infection can be
treated with the equipment they
brought during that 20 million
mile trip.
If not, then we're not sure
what's going to happen.
It's kind of scary.
We can't have a, quote, horribly
infectious, horribly damaging
organism brought back
to Earth from Mars.
Though, the way
I see it, if they
catch some kind of
Martian flu, maybe they
can just go live with
those Mars One crazies
and never come back.
What do you think?
Were you worried
about space infection?
Are you now?
Tell us in the comments below
and find us on social media
so we can be friends.
We'll see you next
time on D News.